Matt Ridley is one of the best-selling
and best regarded science writers on the planet.
He wrote recently that in the face of the Coronavirus pandemic we are about
to find out how robust civilization is,
and that the hardships ahead will be
like nothing we have ever known.
I spoke with Ridley from his home in
northern England. His next book,
"How Innovation Works and Why it Flourishes in Freedom" will be published in May.
We discussed why the Coronavirus caught
him by surprise,
when he thinks we'll be able to reopen the world economy, why Brexit is good for Europe,
and whether he believes that sustained innovation and progress
can take place in authoritarian countries such as China.
Matt Ridley, thank you so much for speaking with Reason.
Nick it's really great to be able
to talk to you and new technology
enables us to do this really quite
easily yes it's and you know the corona
virus if nothing else has been kind of a
kick in the pants to actually start
doing more of this type of stuff we've
it you know I've been writing about how
since at least the mid 90s when the
internet and you know the World Wide Web
really emerged we've been talking about
this kind of thing but we never really
got around to it now we're doing a lot
of things that you know we can do from
the sanctity and the sanctum of our own
home let me start you know one of the
things that was interesting when corona
when the corona virus really hit the
west when it hit North America and
Western Europe or Europe you wrote a
couple of pieces that were striking
because you are the rational optimist
and one of the things that I think was
striking to me and so many of your
readers was there was a pessimism
involved you you talked about how you
thought we would never be faced with
something like this can you explain a
little bit about what that was and how
the emergence of this pandemic has
really shaken you know some of your kind
of core sentiments or or beliefs about
progress well the first thing I should
say is that I've never believed that the
world is the best of all possible worlds
and can't be improved you know that
we've already reached Nirvana so one of
the things I'm very clear about in the
rational optimist is there are still
problems to be solved there are still
threats there are still
I personally think we've been worrying
about the wrong risks and this is a
reminder that we have been doing that
but I'm I rolled my hands up and say I
was not out there saying watch it
there's a pandemic coming right I wish I
had been because then I could claim to
be Nostradamus yes I bet it's not like
you would be any richer right I mean you
might have that you know you would get
that you know people would buy you pints
um at the pub or something but yeah he
offered to be right even that's not
allowed of course well sometime in the
future yeah but back in 1999 I was asked
to write a short book about the future
of disease and I did say in that if we
do have a pandemic that goes crazy and
it's not completely impossible that
combines high contagiousness with high
lethality or relatively high lethality
and then it will be a virus not a
protozoan or a bacterium we're on top of
those enemies pretty well you know it's
not going to be like the plague or like
malaria because it's good yeah we're too
good at beating those big organisms it's
the tiny ones the viruses that were
still pretty bad at um it's gonna be a
respiratory virus why because just look
around you people are coughing and
spluttering all the time respira there
are up to 200 different kinds of
respiratory viruses that we give each
other every winter we call them the
common cold or flu but you know that
some of them are I know viruses some of
them a corona viruses some of them are
adenoviruses you know so there's clearly
something pretty irresistible to the
virus tribe about the the the urban
human population in in terms of ones
that can infect the respiratory tract
and the third thing I said was that it
it might come out of bats and I said
that because a whole bunch of relatively
new diseases have come out of bats in
recent decades and in fact that's been
even more true since I said that cuz
SARS was was after I made that that
remark and the reason for that is
because bats are mammals like us and
it's really simply easy for for a virus
to jump from a mammal to a mammal it's
harder to jump from a bird to a male but
it can be done
it's harder but more to the point bats
are anima
that live in huge crowds they they live
in huge densities there's a cave in
Texas that is a famous bat roost in it
it has roughly the population of Mexico
City
living in that cave so respiratory
viruses are going to enjoy bats and
they're going to enjoy humans and
there's going to be a crossover between
them and when I look back on the lessons
we didn't learn from SARS which was a
really good canary in the coalmine a
very clear warning that these wet
wildlife markets in China were a
dangerous place for crossover between
species because the animals are alive in
the markets it's not the problem is not
bringing meat to markets the problem is
bringing live animals to markets that
are coughing and spluttering now onto
other species and so on and we had a dry
run with a dangerous virus that wasn't
very contagious but it was very
dangerous SARS and we should have said
look this is a real threat now I had
also taken some comfort from the degree
of improvement in molecular biological
knowledge the fact that we can we
sequence SARS in three months or
something that felt like electric fast
because 20 years ago we had in sequence
a single virus and so we knew it's you
know we'd read its recipe we knew its
its defects we knew how to attack it in
theory and I had sort of vaguely in the
back of my mind assumed that vaccine
production had speeded up as well we
sequent this one in days you know
sequencing it though are almost
instantaneous but it turns out as I now
realize reading up that vaccine
development is about as slow as it was
20 years ago and in fact I wrote think
recently about how the whooping cough
vaccine was developed in for four years
flat in the 1930s by two very remarkable
American women and you know four years
is not that much longer than it's
probably going to take us to find a
vaccine to this so so we we have left
the door under deed in one respect or
rather we've let obstacles get in the
way of the development of vaccines I
suspect and that's one of the lessons
we're going to have to learn so
what about you know you know we assumed
that this all started at a wet market in
China China started dealing with it it
was clear to observers as well as you
know health officials and whatnot both
in China and observers in other parts of
the world that something was going on
here and we you know we all discount
information that we got from the Chinese
government because they're gonna lie
about you know how great they are in
certain ways and how safe they are in
others
where where is the failure say in North
America and in Europe to deal with this
because you know we're never going to be
able to control all parts of the world
all of that kind of stuff what do you
think were the fundamental missteps in
the United States and and the United
Kingdom say and in in containing this
right well I think one of the lessons is
that countries like South Korea were
better prepared for this and that was
partly because of SARS
they got more of a fright from SARS in
Asia than we did in the West and they
set up this system of contact tracing
based on on extensive testing that they
were geared up for in a way that we
weren't the West both in the UK and the
US we were very slow to ramp up testing
for the virus and testing turned out to
be crucial I mean that was out Taiwan
and Japan and Korea and Singapore and
others Singapore actually opened a
pandemic hospital and kept it mothballed
after SARS you know so that was
remarkable preparedness so I think
that's that's the one lesson the other
lesson is we relied too much on the
World Health Organization and I think it
has very serious questions to answer
after this if you look at what it was
saying in January it was repeating
untrue Chinese claims that this virus
was not transmissible human-to-human
and it was praising China to the skies
and it was ignoring whistleblowers in
Taiwan and elsewhere and of course this
in recent days there's been a
spectacular piece of embarrassing
footage where World Health Organization
official sort of pretends not to hear
the question when the word Taiwan is you
strain right so I you know
the reliance of the World Health
Organization on China the the close
relationship between its
director-general is the former Ethiopian
health and foreign minister who
developed very close links with China
and was himself a leader of the tigre
Liberation Front which had Chinese
backing these are questions that need to
be looked into because I think if the
World Health Organization had run the
flag up in January we all might have
reacted a bit quicker would you say that
South Korea Taiwan Singapore Japan
although I guess there's some questions
about you know the extent of infection
in Japan but have they are they
exemplary in their response to the
corona virus on the whole yes I mean
what what South Korea did was it it it
tracked it it you know tested lots of
people found out who who they'd been in
contact with issued each of them with an
app so that so that it can go back
through their records and find out who
they came close to which is pretty
remarkable right and that you know the
turned out to be one super spreader
who'd gone to a church and met a huge
number of people tracking down his
contacts proved vital etc so so yes I do
think that track and trace is the is the
technique that's going to work in the
absence of antivirals and vaccines and
so on because what's particularly
dangerous about this virus as I read it
is that it is highly contagious in the
very first few days of infection so
whereas on in SARS it's about eight days
before you infect someone else in covert
19 it's about four days and quite a lot
of this transmission is happening from
people who are symptom free particularly
young people children seem to get very
very mild version they don't even think
there's anything wrong with them and
they go about their normal lives and in
fact people and that is a very dangerous
feature and I'll add one other way in
which my country in particular was not
ready for this or I myself was not ready
for this and that is in January we were
obsessed with brexit we were coming up
to the end of January day breaks it was
going to happen
none of us could pay attention to
anything else and so
I mean that doesn't excuse us being
caught out in February but it does
excuse us perhaps not being a ware of
things in January and of course that's
true of every country you know I mean
America was obsessed with the
presidential campaigns and each one
every four that yeah yeah yeah before
that do you think is there
I mean you are on the one hand you're
you're interested in questions of public
health and of science and and things
like that the other you're a big
defender and promoter of freedom of
individual freedom as you know I mean
it's in the subtitle of your forthcoming
book innovation flourishes and freedom
is there a necessary kind of tension
between public health as it was
practicing in a country like South Korea
we're not talking about China where you
know who knows what's going on there
nailing people who are infected into
their apartments things like that but
say a country like South Korea a country
like Taiwan and the freedom that we take
for granted in kind of view they always
but well they're both in the OECD but in
in the developed world yes there is I
mean we're seeing that very clearly not
just in terms of what you might call the
the technology of tracing people but
also in terms of the police state that
we are now living in you know where
we've got policemen arresting people for
going on unnecessary walks and they they
look like they're enjoying it that's one
of the worrying things right about it
but what I would say to that is if you
want to preserve freedom and not have
this kind of draconian police state
brought down on you and yes I'm afraid
it is necessary to be pretty draconian
when you're in the middle of a pandemic
as it was during a plague in in
centuries past if you want to avoid that
then you need to unleash the freedom to
innovate to solve the problem in good
times and where I think we've been
mistake is we've made it very hard for
people to bring forward medical devices
vaccines drugs etc partly because of
safety regulations but partly because of
just Bureau
pratik growth I mean if you if you take
I have this statistic in my book how
long does it take to get permission
sorry to get what's the word the license
for use a medical device on average and
it's something like 20 months in America
and it's something like 70 months in
Germany that's a black mark against
Europe but it's pretty black mark
against America I mean absolutely take
too long to two months to decide whether
a you know a new hip joint or a new
ventilator or a new personal and
protective equipment in hospital is safe
within that time and the result of that
of course you see what your it is
invisible because what you're achieving
is you're deterring people from going
into these fields you're deterring
people from inventing and innovating in
this area and so you you you can't point
to it and say well you know she show me
that the the product that we could have
licensed a bit quicker well the point
was he never brought it forward because
he looked at how dysfunctional this
market was and stayed away and so it
never got developed so I think that's
one of the issues we have to learn is is
freedom to innovate but you do but there
is attention there is you know I'm not
I'm not the perfect libertarian I'm not
someone who says that in a in the middle
of a dangerous pandemic the state should
have no power to shut down society on
the other hand we can have an argument
about whether we are to some extent
overreacting and whether a you know had
we got the track and trace system they
the stuff we were all worried about but
tech freedom the tech lash you know if
we would we'd not been panicking about
that so much then we might have
developed the that the tracing system
that would have enabled us not to shut
down schools and hospitals and I mean
not hospitals but schools and
playgrounds and things like that
so what is the you know what is the role
of dissent in in a pandemic so you know
I think everybody with with the
exception of you know very doctrinaire
anarchists are gonna say you know what
when there is an emergency that is
widely understood you know different
rules apply and things like that but
when you talk about dissent and things
like that you know England well I guess
I have two questions when should we be
maximizing the ability of people to say
whatever they want to say some people
when you were starting to talk about
China and that's I was just reading a
story that I it was at a major news
outlet today about how you know this is
actually coming out of a Chinese lab
that was testing bats etc so there's a
lot of conspiracy theories that you know
this disease is actually was grown in a
Chinese government lab some kind of bio
terror weapon people like Donald Trump
people like Boris Johnson early on we're
kind of pooh-poohing and you know the
the extent of this or that it wouldn't
be dangerous to begin with we still have
people who are skeptical I was reading
something by Toby young the British
writer who works at co-led and he was
publishing elsewhere talking about how
you know we're simply wrong to shut down
the economy because when you look at it
from a strictly economic point of view
it's better to have more economic
activity because the depression or the
recession we're causing is actually
gonna kill more people you know again
I'm not arguing in favor of any of these
things but having that robust sense of
debate as well as of different
authorities I mean in the United States
and I'm not sure if it's happening in
the United Stated States the FDA and the
CDC keep going back and forth about
whether or not you know is it a good
idea for people to wear masks when they
go outside the FDA is refusing to allow
at-home testing even though I mean you
take the swab at home you send it on
they've they've shown that they failed
as an authority and now they're refusing
to allow other people to kind of act on
their own what is the role of that kind
of dissent and kind of push back against
Authority and in a moment like this well
I think there's no reason to shut down
debate at a moment like this quite the
reverse actually I think that what this
is showing us is there is no monopoly on
wisdom nobody knows exactly what the
right answer is
it's possible we would the the you know
shutting down it's possible that we were
ever reacting at the beginning I mean I
thought we probably were because I'd
seen so many busted flushes so many
Wolf's had come along and we'd cried
wolf and it wasn't a wolf you know bird
flu swine flu SARS MERS you know Ebola
Ebola was a wolf for people in Africa
but it wasn't the rest of the world so
so you know it it's right to have that
debate about whether or not this this is
a real threat and it's also right to
have a debate about what the prognosis
are because there's been a dangerous
tendency in this country and I don't
know whether it's true to the same
extent in the u.s. to believe the models
to put them on a pedestal Imperial
College came out with a model saying
that you know up to half a million
people might be going to dying die
unless we brought in much more draconian
restrictions on people's freedom and
that was used to not to do it cause a
you turning government but to cause them
to bring forward the the lockdown of the
economy that they thought might be
necessary at some point now that model
is not unchallengeable it's got some
very unhappy assumptions in it and it
was immediately challenged by another
model from Oxford University which I
think they went far too far in the other
direction and put some crazy assumptions
in about how quickly we'd get this under
control but that has reminded us that
models are just that they are models you
know they they're not scripture they're
not the territory right there are maps
actly and that by the way is a lesson
for the climate change debate where
models have been again deified too much
due to greater degree but we'll leave
that on one side for the moment so while
I I don't want to stop anybody coming
out with a a an article saying here's my
evidence why the Chinese invented it or
here's my evidence why it's easily cured
with this crack here that I've got made
out of dandelions brewed at midnight
under the full moon or whatever it might
we let a thousand flowers bloom in this
let everybody say what that what they
want but let them produce their evidence
and let them put up with a bit of
criticism if their evidence is bad
that's the thing so I don't mind the the
claims as long as the counterclaims are
out there and in the case of the idea
that it's a Chinese bio weapon I've seen
very good molecular biological evidence
so that is extremely implausible it's
also extremely implausible that it came
out of a Chinese lab for various again
molecular biology reasons so I don't
object to the theory being advanced but
I don't think anyone should object a bit
being severely criticized - so my you
know I defend defend with my life that
the right fear to say what you want is
but I also defend my right to criticise
you for saying I think you know part of
the role of scepticism my girlfriend was
saying that when a relative of hers read
your take on it he you know finds you to
be credible that was that skepticism or
the or the ability of you to publicly
discuss what you're thinking and how it
changes your mind that helped him take
things more seriously so that's another
role of skepticism certainly as somebody
who has poo pooed alarmism about many
different things you know the from the
population explosion through to climate
change you know I've I've cataloged how
my life was nearly ruined as a youngster
by people scaring me about the future of
the world and I feel very level very
strongly that greater Tim Berg's life is
being ruined by people today and
likewise and so I'm all for debunking
scares so for me as someone who's almost
a professional deep bunker of scares to
come out and say this one is quite scary
and we just need to take you seriously
has made some of my friends stop and
think you know how far are long are we
to or how do we start to figure out are
we in the middle of things or you know
are the cases cresting or is the
pandemic cresting or are we in the first
you know we don't even realize where we
haven't even gotten our boots on yet and
this stuff is going to be around for a
very long time what are the markers that
go into figuring out where we are
whether or not what we're doing is
working and when do we kind of reopen
things yeah short answer I don't know
and I haven't got a model and even if I
did I wouldn't believe it because it'll
depend on assumptions but but the longer
answer is that I see evidence that the
most of the countries that have brought
in lockdowns three weeks ago like Italy
and Spain are beginning to see the
numbers crest they're not you know
they're probably going to go on going up
for a while but they're not going up as
fast and so the worst is not over yet
but the worst may be over within some
weeks now it would be amazing if the
lockdowns weren't having some effect I
mean I I haven't been within two metres
of anyone except my wife for two weeks
now that means that I can't have got it
in that time and I can't have given it
in that time except to her obviously she
likewise hasn't been so and in that
sense we must be having an effect what
we don't really know in my view is which
measures are working best you know is it
you know was closing the schools a good
idea or a bad idea because it sent kids
back to stay with their grandparents and
the grandparents are more risk the way I
see it developing is that we will get
better at curing people who get it you
know some of these things
hydroxychloroquine and things like that
may be helpful the way in which you just
simply lying patients on their front not
their backs when you're ventilating them
apparently is what is helping you know
so we're going to get a little better at
saving lives we're going to ramp up the
capacity for hospitalization for
ventilators and so on we're going to
improve the testing over the next few
weeks so that we're going to get better
at contact tracing and once we've done
that we can start to lift these
restrictions because we can start to say
when it does flare up we can quickly
track down who's at risk and put them
under lock and key rather than the whole
of society and eventually get to the
point where the only people who have got
to be really careful are the very
vulnerable
and the rest of us can get on with a
relatively normal life now will that
happen in April I doubt it will it
happen in May I hope so
will it happen in June it I'm jolly well
think so because I don't think we I mean
I think that's the point where we start
to take Toby Young's arithmetic very
seriously and say sorry we're killing
more people by leaving them you know
locked up with abusive partners alone
and in danger of committing suicide
worklists and unable to you know feed
themselves properly more prone to take
drugs and alcohol whatever it might be
you know there's a whole bunch of things
that'll be going wrong with society
because of this lockdown and at that at
some point that overwork that's a bigger
problem than the corona Busters there
are there are good things about this
virus sorry that's not the right word
there are no good things about it but
there are less bad things namely the big
one is that it does not kill children
I mean imagine every other plague
including influenza was quite good at
killing kids you know smallpox was
lethal among children plague was was
lethal to children we're incredibly
lucky in that respect that this is not
not killing children but of course that
is contributed to the young feeling
somewhat invulnerable and that's made it
harder for them to take seriously the
the restrictions or movements what are
the kinds of you know we've been talking
mostly about the public health
interventions and an kind of fallout
from all of this what about the economic
you know responses in the United States
the the federal government just passed
the single largest spending bill in
history I was talking to a congressman
yesterday who said you know when the
Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor we didn't
pass a spending bill we declared war on
the current we declared war on our
enemies you know is there from an
economic point of view what are the
types of responses that again are
consistent with limited government you
know that that are likely to work and
what are the ones that are likely to do
more damage I mean we're still digging
out of the the if they kind of add on
effects of the bailouts during the
financial crisis twelve years ago yeah I
think the UK paid off its last debt from
the Napoleonic Wars just a few years ago
now so that mean that there is no doubt
when you when you hugely increase the
scope of government it tends not to
retreat as fast as you would like
Britain didn't end food rationing till
something like 1954 and the argument was
always well you know there are some
people at the bottom society who might
not be able to afford food well it turns
out the reason they couldn't afford food
was because food was being rushed and so
the supply wasn't responding to demand
in the same way and so the price wasn't
coming down do you see what I mean it
was a circular argument so and there is
a real danger that what we've done is
nationalized huge threats of the economy
we'll find it very hard on do it the
moment you start to say right we can we
can relax this again and we can no will
no longer subsidize you for the faith
for the fact that your business is
struggling a lot of people will say hang
on I'm gonna go bust of that happiness
and you know so you will you will you
will see that on the other hand the idea
that the government steps in and makes
it possible for businesses to take over
during this period because we think is
temporary
might be quite a reasonable one I mean
in other words you know if everyone was
just to sort of say right I'm closing
down my business overnight it would be
harder to start the economy up again on
the other hand again there's got to be a
degree of rethinking of how we run the
economy in the wake of this there's a
whole bunch of things that we can we can
take a bit of a blank slate approach
things that we've said for years well
you can't do that because there's huge
vested interests well maybe when we
restart we can can you give an example
of some of the other the workforce rules
or the you know regulations that have
kind of been shown to be less essential
then maybe we thought yeah well for a
start the ones around product safety and
you know not all of them obviously you
know we've got to have
but there's but it's clear that you know
if we suddenly say right let's tear up
some of these regulations in order to
respond quickly well then we shouldn't
be doing that anyway I mean if some of
these regulations were unnecessary and a
lot of reporting requirements an awful
lot of what's coming in recent years is
about you know sending bits of paper
from one person to another and this is
now being said well we don't need do
that we don't need to get that bit of
paper from you yeah we'll just forget
that get the grant out to you straight
away a lot of the complication around
tax you know it turns out to be much
simpler to run a tax system that than we
thought so I think we need to have a
real drains up look at what we what we
don't need to do and likewise we need to
have a look at how we as individuals not
just as government run society and
that's things like video conferencing
things like what you and I are doing
right now I'm gonna try and insist that
I have an awful lot of fewer
face-to-face meetings and an awful lot
more meetings of this kind because
they're jolly efficient right time use
and it turns out the technology is
really advanced five or ten years ago if
you did this we'd have dropouts we'd
have freeze ups you know there'd be all
sorts of stuff that wouldn't quite work
I remember trying to do a lecture to
Texas down the line about eight years
ago and there was a 10-minute delay oh
no I don't mean a two-minute delay or
something but it was you know
paralytically difficult in those
conditions and I I do want to point out
that you are in a makeshift recording
booth because you were doing the audio
version so this is you know this is your
makeshift sound booth you're like it's
like the Abbey Road you know studios or
something out there well it was due to
record the audio version of my book last
week in the week before and four days
blocked out in the diary for doing that
in the studio in London became clear I
wasn't going to be in London I was gonna
be at home in the north of England and
nobody else was going to be in the
studio either because of social
distancing so we set it up in such a way
that I put some padding in a closet
which doesn't have an outside window so
there's very little extraneous noise and
I shut the door on the corridor so that
nobody walks past etc ten
got beautiful acoustics I've got a
ready-made studio here and all you do is
press record on QuickTime and then send
the file to that produce at the other
end and somebody edits it and it's it's
just beautiful so the you know we're
discovering right things I'm the number
of people I've spoke to say you know
what regular weekly meeting is happening
at half the time now right right I think
let's talk about the new book renovation
works and wide flourishes and freedom
what is the you know I be we've got
nothing but time because we're not going
anywhere but give me the elevator pitch
give me I'd and of course we're gonna be
out of elevators for a long time to come
at least the Vettii what else is in them
but what is the basis of how innovation
works and why flourishes and freedom
well it it starts from the point that
innovation is probably the most
important thing that happens in the
world I mean the fact that people invent
new ways of reorganizing the atoms and
molecules of the world to be convenient
to us is what's made us prosperous and
it's what's made us interesting in the
last 200 years etc it's but it's the big
theme of the last couple hundred years
and yet it's a mysterious process and I
start from the the point that actually
nobody really knows why innovation
happens in one place not another why it
happens to us and not to other animals
why it happens at some times and in some
technologies and not at other times and
now the technologies why did my
grandparents experience incredible
incredible changes in transport but very
little in computers and communication
whereas I've had exactly the opposite
experience very little change in
transported my lifetime very big changes
in computers and communication we don't
know we don't know the answer to most of
these questions so it's a mysterious
process but it's not entirely mysterious
of course we know some things about it
and what I do in the book is I tell
stories I tell the story of the
invention of the steam engine the
invention of the search engine the
invention of vaccines the invention of
vaping the invention of aeroplanes the
invention of cars you know I just just
tell lots of relatively short stories
about how people came up with this and
from these I draw some general points
the first is that
innovation is different from invention
that coming up with the first prototype
or the first idea is not the end of the
story there's a huge amount of effort
goes into turning that into something
practical something affordable something
reliable that people can actually use
and that's the process of innovation
that is necessary after the process of
invention if you like and it's not quite
that simple anyway here it's often and
the inventor likes to get the credit and
often comes up with a completely fake
story and this is another point I make
that these stories are always made up
about how an apple fell on his head or
he jumped out of the bath with an
insight around or you know the light
bulb went on above his head run and
actually it's a much more gradual
process it's a more incremental process
it's a more collaborative process
virtually every discovery and invention
has rival discoverers saying hang on I
thought of that 221 different people
came up with the idea of the light bulb
around the same time if Thomas Edison
had been run over by a tram we'd still
have light bulbs but what Edison did
brilliantly and this is another theme of
my book is that he realized that
innovation is a product innovation is
something you can set out to produce you
can set up an innovation Factory and
what you've got to do in that Factory is
trial and error
that's the big theme that comes out
again and again from all the innovators
is you you try different things you
experiment and you reinforce the things
that work and you discard the things
that don't work well part from the
people who are kind of creating those
factories and I guess what Edison was
called The Wizard of Menlo Park right he
had a big you know a factory of
factories essentially are there larger
kind of social cultural economic
political arrangements or institutions
that lend themselves to more innovation
rather than less definitely and I mean
obviously Liberty is a big part of this
it helps to have people free to do
things it's amazing how much resistance
there is to innovation from society but
also from rule
I mean I tell the story of coffee as an
innovation coffee comes into Western
Europe around 1500 and everywhere rulers
try to ban it and you know the coffee
wars go on for a couple hundred years
now why are they doing this two reasons
one because the wine industry is
lobbying them to ban it okay and two
because coffee tends to be drunk in
coffee houses and the trouble with
coffee houses is that people sit in them
and they chat about the people running
society and they're rude about them and
kings spotted this and said hang on we
can't have coffee house these people
might talk about me yeah so a huge
amount of resistance to innovation and
so somehow you've got to set up society
so you can get around that resistance
and that means giving people a certain
amount of Liberty and one way to do that
it emerges is to have fragmented
governance so to be a federal structure
or a fragmented continent so Europe's
great advantage when it got going was
that it had lots of different small
countries and lots of innovate inventors
and innovators moved from one country to
another to find a more congenial regime
and that couldn't happen in China it had
happened in China interestingly 500
years before when China was incredibly
innovative because China was at that
stage fragmented into about five
kingdoms and they were rival risks with
each other but by the time the sort of
fifteen hundred's come along the main
empires in charge and that has a very
top-down structure in which nothing can
be done unless it's got a license from
the mandarins no merchant can move
because he might you know bring a bad
idea from one place to another you
literally have to stay where you're born
unless you get a license to travel you
know it couldn't be worse as a system
for suppressing innovation so so freedom
to exchange ideas because there is no
innovation that is a single idea every
innovation is a recombinant phenomenon
if combined so are you are you
predicting now with the arrive let's
forget about karana virus
brexit then that means that the UK is
ready to retake its leading role as an
innovative place because it's now not
going to be governed by Brussels or that
I'm being facetious but you know we it
is it breaks better good is that is it
is it good for innovation or should it
be yes is the short answer and I mean
there are other problems with the
breakup of the U and it's not gonna
happen overnight although I think
coronavirus may accelerate the breakup
of the eurozone and but I give them
several examples in the book of how the
European Union is particularly inimical
to innovation how on the whole it is a
system that is designed to stop
innovation so three quick examples one
is the utter failure to produce a
digital giant to rival Amazon Google etc
in Europe despite having lots of tech
companies lots of digital industry and
that's largely down to a regulatory
phenomenon once you drill down into it
the second is biotechnology and gene
editing where Europe decided to have a
one-size-fits-all policy that was
essentially antithetical to both
technologies he did it by delay rather
than banning but it takes so long to get
approval for a genetically modified crop
in Europe that nobody even tries anymore
so that's coming out and the third is a
beautiful little example of a Sir James
Dyson who's a very good British
innovator who came up with the bagless
vacuum cleaner and the European
regulations said that by vacuum unlike
international regulations followed by
every other country European regulation
said that vacuum cleaners must be tested
without dust and he said this is
ridiculous no point of a vacuum cleaners
to be tested with dust
well it turned out they've been lobbied
by the big German bagged vacuum cleaner
manufacturers who said who had to ramp
up the power of their vacuums in order
to cope with dust as their bags got
clogged so they had this software that
caused the vacuum to increase its power
usage and this was running into problems
the regulations for trying to reduce the
power hunger of household goods so he
goes to court and the court rules
against him on the grounds that it's
impractical to protest them with dust
and so he does a freedom of information
thing to find out why the court thought
this and he discovers a huge ream of
Correspondence from the German industry
to the German members of the court
asking them to intervene on their behalf
so he appeals and he appeals to the
European Court of Justice and he wins
and the European of course just his
hands the decision back down to the
court to the General Court saying right
now please reverse your decision and the
General Court reverses its decision five
years have passed during this process by
which time he's lost his first mover
advantage the Chinese have moved into
the market etc etc and it's no surprise
that James Dyson became a strong
advocate of the UK leaving the European
Union and we want to be the kind of
country that behaves like Singapore and
Hong Kong but on a bigger scale free
trading open to competition and trying
to be competitive with others now
there's a bunch of us that want that and
there are others that don't and wish
we'd never left the European Union but
for me the big reason for brexit was
because the European Union places
obstacles in the way of innovation on
behalf of incumbent vested interests do
you think globally are we in an era now
where there are multiple power centers
around the world I mean there's China
there's the United States there's the EU
you know the breakaway Republic of the
United Kingdom now but other parts of
the world are growing in leaps and
bounds in terms of you know wealth and
distribution of power and knowledge are
we in a good phase for innovation or are
we kind of constantly moving towards
more and more centralization I'm a
little worried about that because
America has been the the the the leader
the driver the engine of innovation for
most of the last century and
particularly California and it's been
terrific I mean it's it's kept the flame
alive when others want to
to snap it out obviously the fascist and
communist dictatorships wanted to shut
it down effectively they wouldn't have
been what they had said they were doing
but they were extremely bad at
innovation and without America we would
be in we'd be really struggling for
innovative products an America to some
extent has lost its edge in that topic
so has the work though is Europe now
China is picking up the ball and China
is innovating in a way that America did
a century ago it's fast its nimble it's
it's without much in the way of
regulations and rules and and this is a
case where it's not necessarily
inventive per se but it is taking other
people's inventions and bringing them to
scale to some extent but I think China
has gone beyond catch up myself you know
I think it's I mean if you look at what
they're doing with you know consumer
practices in the market in terms of how
you pay for a meal how you pay for
blacks you know all this kind of thing
you know they're you know they've lived
left credit cards behind you know that
that if you look at what they're doing
with social media with online fine fine
or no retail online finance things like
that that they're they're exploring new
possibilities right the worry is does
this work if an authoritarian regime is
running it you know if the world leader
on innovation is north Oratory regime i
say innovation flourishes in freedom how
do i square that with run China being
the most innovative part of the world
now well the answer is quite easy
actually if you look at the life of an
entrepreneur in China
he's pretty free as long as he doesn't
annoy the Communist Party in other words
um once you once you drill below the top
level there's very little of the petty
bureaucracy and regulations together so
are you saying China is and I'm talking
you from New York City that this is
certainly an example of this I suspect
London is where you have these
metropolis Azure Paris where there is
this vast artifice of rules and
regulation there's a
lot of government a lot of controls but
then if you're in the city you can
pretty much live however you want
without ever talking to anybody in a
position of authority are you saying
China is kind of like that yes I think I
am I think you know that if you want to
set up political and innovative
political party in China good luck but
if you want this if you want to invent a
new widget you're off to the races now
it worries me that you know for me
political and intellectual and
ideological Liberty goes alongside
technological Liberty and that without
the former you're gonna struggle to
produce enough of the latter in Duke
eventually so either China has got to
liberalize eventually or other parts of
the world have got to pick up the the
torch yeah do you think thanks um India
will play a big part in the 21st century
Oh as a counterweight perhaps
libertarian place India you know it's
always been a it's always had a lot of
what you might call spontaneous order or
I mean it's effectively uncover noble
right but it is a very big and to two
biggest and all that yeah but it but but
you know and a lot of its innovative
brains of left India for California and
other places in recent decades and I
think that's happening less and less so
I would say between them those two will
be big engines but look at countries
like Brazil and Indonesia you know I
think there's a lot happening and what's
very exciting about the last decade
since I wrote the rational optimist is
how wealthy Africa's becoming well
wealth is the wrong word it's not yet
wealthy but how much less poor it's
becoming weak the growth of economies in
Africa is now on a scale of what the
Asian Tigers were doing 20 years before
and a lot of people said that couldn't
happen
Ethiopia has doubled its average income
in ten years that's extraordinary do you
think that's something to bring it back
to coronavirus the way that the Chinese
government has handled the corona virus
is that potentially you know I guess I'm
going back to
decades ago Milton Friedman said that
you know you you economic freedom
happens people get wealthier when they
have more money they start to demand
political freedom he seemed to predict
the rise of the Tiananmen Square
movement or the Liberty movement in
China in the 80s that's gone away and a
lot of people are saying well he's been
disproven with the rise of the current
Chinese government actually you can have
continued economic prosperity and
increasingly authoritarian state
practices do you think that the
coronavirus by kind of showing the hand
of the government of the Chinese
government as well as being incompetent
might that bring back a kind of sense of
you know the need for lived freedom in
China in a or political freedom I rather
hope so I think this is an epochal
moment and it could go very well in the
way you're describing or it could go
very badly because I think there's going
to be a big rethink about the relation
between the West and China in economic
relations as well as everything else in
the wake of this for example the just
before all this happened
Britain was having a big round with
America about the use of highway
products in our 5g rollout and we were
insisting that no we did want trying to
have a role didn't don't worry where
they won't be able to be in the core of
it and use it to spy or shut shutters
down an America was saying you're being
naive I think the people who agree with
America on that in the UK will now have
the upper hand and I suspect will be a
rolling back of that issue and I think
there's going to be a lot of people
saying we don't want our supply chains
to be as reliant on China as they were
now that could lead and of course this
is against a background of an economic
trade war between the Trump
administration and China anyway that
could lead to the sort of trade disputes
that Japan got into with the rest of the
world in the 1930s and that didn't end
well right you know Japan said well
if you're not going to let us have
rubber then we'll have to go and invade
South East Asia and get our own rubber
oh that's a right but crude cartoon
version of what happened but there's
some truth in it so I can't see this
ending badly and of course it's at a
time when for whatever reason strong men
have emerged as leaders all over the
world whether you called Donald Trump a
strong man I don't know but he there's
an element of that about him and Modi
and bolts and arrow and shooting thing
for bond etc or burn and co and and I
personally think there's an element of
technological determinism here that I
think social media and the
disintermediation of the media getting
rid of the middleman getting rid of
broadcast networks and things like that
has played a large role in this just as
the invention of radio played a large
role in the rise of the dictators in the
1920's 1930's and just as they mention a
print played a role in the reformation
in the 1500 so I'm I think technologies
do have an influence on this and I have
to say I was naively optimistic about
what the internet would do to human
conversation we would all see each
other's point of view we did and we
realized we've really disliked you know
now this is the most bizarre thing is
that even as we have more distributed
conversations of more point-to-point
conversations we are so down on you know
whatever we want to call social media
it's it's a little bit odd because it's
there's no question you know places like
the BBC and even the Chinese Communist
Party in many ways has less power less
you know less univocal power than it's
ever had but that's a very good thing no
because there was a tremendously
condescending and patronizing view among
the intelligentsia that they should tell
you what the news was very recently and
we were rebelling against that and just
you know just the last two weeks have
shown us how much we can communicate
means with our friends I mean about you
but I'm inundated with funny videos
oh well it's you know the funny ones I
don't mind it's the unfunny one so those
audio I don't have had a filter quite
yet so just as a final note you know
what is the is is there a single marker
in the corona virus pandemic that we can
look for and we say okay with this
that signal goes up where that's a bad
choice of words when this flare lights
up the sky we know that were you know
we're getting closer to the end rather
than stuck at the beginning well it's
going to be in the statistics of cases I
think that's that's what you're looking
for but it might also be in treatment or
prophylaxis you know I I don't rule out
that with the ferment of innovation
we're about to unleash that we will come
upon something that really is a
preventive action or a preventive you
know it would be for example we might
find out that it's not door handles it's
you know something else which is 90
percent of the spread if you see what I
mean you know it's unlikely to be
everything that it's spreading but and
if we can really identify these I think
think they will they will change it I
mean and you know I don't give up hope
of a rapid vaccine I mean the the
problem with vaccines and the reason it
takes so long is because you've got to
test them in animals you can't develop
an animal model you've got to check
where they work well this is some place
where innovation needs to happen right I
mean we can't be using a hundred year
old you know medical practices right now
quite right and what I the one of the
things I've been strongly saying is that
this crisis reminds us that innovation
is not an optional extra that we can
decide whether we want or not it's a
very very important thing and we have
neglected it at our peril we've we've
experienced an innovation famine in
recent years we've done plenty of
digital innovation as Peter deal is
often said but you know if you look at
the amount of innovation in drugs and
vaccines it's been pathetic in the last
20 years and we're now paying the price
for that so this shows us we need more
innovation not less
and we need to be prepared to not take
silly risks but prepared to you know run
some reasonable hazards in order to
achieve great goods
we've been far too precautionary about
the cures and we are on eclis we haven't
been precautionary enough about the risk
of a pandemic itself well we're going to
leave it there and just for a final work
for innovation I do want to remind
people that we are talking to Matt
Ridley from his closet somewhere in the
north of England so something right is
happening we will be beaming this out to
the four planets Matt Ridley author of
the forthcoming book how innovation
works and why it flourishes and freedom
thanks so much for talking to reason
thank you Nick very much